se le consideraba menos rígido más
abierto occidente pero al igual que
bashar al assad en síria está claro que
la juventud de una breve estancia en
europa no son suficientes para convertir
a los hijos de los dictadores en grandes
demócratas en corea del norte kim
jong-un que celebra su décimo
aniversario en el poder ha demostrado
ser al menos tan duro como su padre kim
jong-il a quien los ciudadanos han
llegado a rendir un homenaje no siempre
espontáneo en uno de los regímenes más
represivos del mundo y lo que más al
estar aquí en la colina de manzur y ver
la imagen de nuestro gran general kim
jong-il con su sonrisa no puede evitar
que se me salgan las lágrimas ciudad
el viejo dicho dice que el tiempo pasa y
todo cambia pero aunque el tiempo pase
seguimos echando de menos a nuestro
general un inmigrante murió no invitado
al disparar repetidamente misiles para
probar el arsenal de corea del norte y
suponer una amenaza para la región
el líder autoritario kim jong-un se ha
ganado el apodo de hombre cohete las
esperanzas de cambio ya no convencen a
muchos expertos
cuando se observa la última década con
kim jong-un en el poder para garantizar
su seguridad es muy probable que corea
del norte siga esgrimiento tanto la
zanahoria como el garrote con falsas
conversaciones de paz y con esta
estrategia de brinkmann psíquico juzgar
con profundidad los tres encuentros con
el expresidente estadounidense donald
trump han sido a juicio de observadores
una ilusión y el brote de kobe 19 ha
sido desde entonces una formidable
excusa para que kim jong-un cierra aún
más corea del norte donde amenazan la
hambruna y los controles fronterizos
especialmente estrictos cada vez son
menos los disidentes que logran salir
del país